i
[Música]
ah
el gobierno de joe biden pidió un cambio
de rumbo al gobierno de daniel ortega al
tiempo que denunció la intensificación
de la represión en nicaragua que vive
una crisis política social y económica
desde 2018 byd en que promueve un
ambicioso plan de reforma migratoria en
eeuu que representaría la regularización
de al menos 10 millones de
indocumentados en ese país del norte y
que impactaría probablemente la vida de
miles de centroamericanos propone
invertir al menos 4 mil millones de
dólares en los próximos cuatro años de
su gobierno para que los gobiernos de
centroamérica reduzcan la pobreza la
violencia y la corrupción
este plan migratorio también propone la
creación de centros de procesamiento
para refugiados de forma que las
solicitudes de asilo se realicen en
centroamérica y no en la frontera de
eeuu
[Música]
el gobierno de honduras ve con marcado
optimismo que el nuevo presidente de los
eeuu joe baile siga apoyando a través de
la alianza de la prosperidad a los
países que integran el triángulo del
norte así mismo los programas
encaminados a erradicar el narcotráfico
la corrupción los efectos del cambio
climático y programas de ayuda social by
day en su nueva administración que
prometió aumentar a 4 mil millones de
dólares el apoyo a los países que
integran el triángulo del norte que son
honduras el salvador y guatemala
enfocados en temas migratorios y de esta
manera evitar la salida de caravanas de
emigrantes que pretenden ingresar de
manera ilegal a los estados unidos
también el gobierno de juan orlando
hernández esperan que la nueva
administración asigne a un embajador en
este país ya que no lo tienen desde el
2017 la misión diplomática
estadounidense está siendo dirigida por
encargadas de negocios
[Música]
a casi un mes de su llegada a la casa
blanca joe biden ha impulsado acciones
que podrían verse como un giro en la
política exterior hacia el triángulo
norte de centroamérica alejada del
cierre de fronteras y cancelación de
beneficios migratorios de la
administración trump como primera medida
el departamento de estado anunció la
suspensión inmediata de los acuerdos de
cooperación con guatemala honduras y el
salvador que obligaban a aplicantes y
asilo en eeuu a permanecer en estos
países mientras obtenían una resolución
sin embargo las autoridades
norteamericanas enfatizaron en que la
reducción de restricciones no equivale a
una política de fronteras abiertas para
los habitantes de la región de la que
provienen muchos de los migrantes de las
caravanas por otra parte el gobierno
estadounidense ha anunciado que
publicará nombres de personas
sospechosas de vínculos con casos de
corrupción y socavamiento de las
instituciones democráticas en las que
presuntamente aparecerían políticos
regionales de alto rango lo que podría
tensar las relaciones de algunos estados
con el país norte
[Música]